[Music]
you were texting and I was watching how
fast you text yet and it blew my mind
you're you're incredible I'm a rabid
texter yes so and accurate is not always
accurate no but um yeah I'm a big texter
and um oh boy okay so a few days ago
what happened was I have this friend
this kid friend I call him little David
and every year he writes his play and
I'm in it and it's wonderful and he's a
great you know young aspiring writer and
I'm just you know he's he's a doll yeah
anyhow so uh I often times in the middle
of the night I like to send texts like
inspiring text I guess that's nice of
you like an inspirational message to
someone or thank you or whatever I'm
like thinking about you I can't sleep no
no that sounds creepy no no it wasn't
like that
but those ones and I delete no no no but
yes so anyway so I was like you know I
should send little David a text and so I
thought I wrote him you're a talented
writer
exclamation point um keep at it
exclamation point uh you got a big
future ahead of you happy face that's
nice right yeah so I sent it over to him
and then the next morning I didn't hear
anything I checked my you know phone and
I didn't get a text back and then the
next day I didn't get a text back and
then I'm like what what what's up a
little David yeah so I took my dick I
sent it to Larry David
[Applause]
I don't have all the people to get that
message you are Dave pointed writer yeah
I think you're onto something you know
stick with it okay David yeah
are you kidding that's fantastic that's
famous mortified and also that's the
face he would make getting that text
back huh mortified still it's kind of a
dick move on his part to not respond I
disagree with it and thank everyone in
Hollywood cool